so it's early Monday morning and I've
been wanting to make a Monday morning
video for a long time but finally d-roc
we're doing it so real quick this is
just a rant very simple and something
that I want you to pass on or watch
every Monday morning because the level
of complaining is unacceptable look what
if I told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life what if I told you
you died this week would you complain
about your crap job or that test you
don't want to take I doubt it
you would go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
pumped right now if you're begrudging
what you're about to do it here if
you're not looking forward to it look I
respect practicality you got to go
through school because your parents want
to you got to pay your rent you got
screwed in loans I get it
but please recognize the world we're
living in we're living in a world where
there's so much more opportunity this
internet thing created way more
opportunity for all of us way more I
mean look you might not even be alive
like your mom and dad could have had sex
like three minutes later and you
wouldn't even exist and you're
complaining you could have ended up
being the bus a tree I just don't get
the mentality of being head down sad on
a Monday morning I'm gonna make Monday
morning my I'm gonna make you Saturday
Monday morning that's what I want to do
every morning and that's what I want
from you please take a step back and
think about how awesome it actually is
and then recognize that you can attack
the world in a totally different way
because you were lucky enough to be born
during this era you Monday